-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well,
and now if you don't mind
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden today declared
a major disaster in Florida,
and then Florida in turn
declared Biden a major disaster.
[ Laughter ]
The White House released
a 44-page plan yesterday
to fight hunger.
It's just
the Cheesecake Factory menu.
[ Laughter ]
Before the government runs out
of money tomorrow,
Congress is reportedly
set to pass stopgap legislation
to keep the government funded
through 2 1/2 more months.
Is it just me,
or is the government always
waiting until the last minute
to fund itself?
The federal government is like
a kid running for the school bus
with one pant leg on
holding a waffle.
[ Laughter ]
Queen Elizabeth's death
certificate was released today
and said that
she died of old age,
a condition she battled
for nearly 30 years.
[ Laughter ]
At a recent panel,
Texas Senator Ted Cruz
was booed by the crowd
after he said that
the best way
to stop school shootings
was to increase police presence
on campuses.
Cruz hadn't been booed that bad
since the last time
he walked into his house.
"Hey, family."
"Boo!"
Republican operatives
in Pennsylvania
are reportedly trying to push
the unfounded theory
that Democratic Senate candidate
and lieutenant governor
John Fetterman
is affiliated with a gang.
Even worse, they're trying to
push the unfounded theory
that Dr. Oz is affiliated
with Pennsylvania.
[ Laughter ]
The Netflix reality dating show
"Love Is Blind"
is reportedly casting
for a new season
to be set in Washington, D.C.
Said one contestant,
"Okay, so he's really quiet,
but an amazing listener."
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
Tom Hanks said that
he made a ton of movies,
but added that he thinks
"four of them are pretty good,"
and then Vin Diesel said, "I've
also made a ton of movies."
[ Laughter ]
Tom Hanks announced
in the same interview
that next year he will release
his debut novel,
and no surprise here --
it's called
"World War II in Space."
[ Light laughter ]
Maybe a little surprise here.
And finally the airline
Virgin Atlantic yesterday
unveiled its new
gender-neutral uniform policy.
Flight attendants
can choose to wear
either pants, a skirt,
or the Chalamet.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.